Hello CZsWorld.
Happy Holidays. By the time you're watching this it will be Christmas which means only 341 days until Halloween.
In honor of this holiday season, a couple friends and I decided to do a YouTube horror channel gift exchange,
and my package from How Bizarre has finally arrived.
So I'm going to do a little unboxing.
First we got this note: "Do not open before X-mas".
We're planning to upload these videos on the 25th so...
I'm not really sure what you want me to do, I'm gonna have to open this one way or another.
Look at this, the moment I cut into that thing I just feel this sharp pain cutting into my wrist.
--no idea what is going--
No way! I used to love this thing when I was a kid! This is going to be great!
How Bizarre: YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE THAT.
Let this be a cautionary tale to you all.
NEVER open before Christmas.
Also, be sure to like this video and comment what your favorite holiday gift was this year.
DO NOT forget to subscribe.
Click here to see the present that I sent to Superfreak Media.
Be sure to subscribe to both Superfreak and How Bizarre.
You will not receive another warning.
Oh, you're still here.
I just wanted to say thank you for making 2015 a great year.
You guys, the fans, are really what make CZsWorld into a thing; make it possible.
So thank you so much for watching.
We had a really great year this year, we did Hello Darkness, Final Set...
a bunch of short films and everyone's new favorite thing, Microhorror.
And stick around for 2016 because there's a lot of big things planned for then too.
Just a word of caution,
be careful. Have a safe holidays, because...
if you're using a box cutter to open your presents like I did...
they tend to be sharp,
and while this may not have been real blood...
this might have been, so have a safe holiday season.
Use caution with sharp objects.
So that's all I got for you in 2015.
Please check out Superfreak's video, you're definitely going to want to see what I sent to him.
I'll see you on the other side in 2016.
Grandma's Cookies sure are good.